[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what's going on it's jake from joke
world today we're doing a video
recapping theovon's podcast studios and
history behind them so we're only
focusing on the guest episodes of this
past weekend not the solo episodes so
the four main studios that he used were
the chris farley mural studio podcast
ville the simpsons studio uh then the
one with like the red backdrop and the
wooden sign for this past weekend and
then the current one in nashville his
first guest in the chris farley studio
was on march 30th 2018 and it was
jaymore episode 84 of this past weekend
you're the first guest that we've ever
had why is that well we had one game we
had uh one man who had some issues uh
who i met at the dmv one time but he
hasn't
i don't know
i can't believe he was available oh yeah
the dude at the dmv oh he came in the
hot ticket he was shining man he came i
mean it seemed like somebody just
you know just hidden just electricity in
his eyes boy when he showed up he was
pretty bent out this man steven and uh
and i haven't been able to get a hold of
him i've called him a couple times the
most viewed episode from the studios
jordan peterson episode 110. it's one
thing i really like about joe rogan
you know he's an absolute bloody monster
he's really really really tough yeah and
yet
he's very truthful he's very forthright
like and all that toughness is
integrated into his character and it
makes him a formidable interviewer
because you can tell like he won't budge
no not a bit he's also extraordinarily
funny so he's cool to see him
i think he really is a remarkable person
and i've watched lots of people he is
he's like four standard deviations above
the mean and tough he's four standard
deviations above the mean and smart and
he's four standard deviations above the
mean and funny yeah that's a hell of a
guy man he's like to me he's like a
point and he's also a father of three
girls which is right it's just comical
it's so comfortable did you see his his
uh take on the kardashians oh my god
it's in his last comedy special and he
talks about oh wait yeah you know i've
seen that on stage
being dominated by women which
which he is at the moment it's so
comical he's like a poignant teddy bear
that joined the marines
then on july 11 2019 he moved to
podcastville the simpsons studio this is
my most nostalgic this past weekend's
studio personally his first guest in
there was episode 213 and it was tom
segura i don't have a marriage
experience yeah i've been in you know
i've had bad sex with probably with
countless women hundreds we're about to
say hundreds oh yeah
oh yeah
dude nobody's provided more bad sex
across america than your boy right here
really oh
i'll put that up against anybody bruh
you know what i'm saying what do you
think
do you play the game
do you think you know your number
no i don't you don't but you don't want
to even get into it no i don't i mean i
know it's probably a decent number
it's probably something brendan shaw
couldn't count to let's put it there
but he can't count that i know he can't
bro have you seen his little accountant
thing no oh it's crazy really you know
those things that kids have with the
sliders
pocket abacus yeah he's like two
three four and he sounds it out
and then one time he ate one of the
things off of it so now he doesn't even
know
that
the ten's really nice yeah yeah yeah
the other day i heard him say carry the
40. and i'm like he's done
he's done man we get a bonus clip from
that one because no surprise it was also
the most viewed episode from podcast
film number 213 tom segura again there
was another club that these dudes
owned to get like friends
and one of the dudes
was a recovering addict
his main choice was crack and he had but
he had like a very addictive he's a
hufflepuff boy i was [ __ ] sniffing
dory yeah yeah yeah he was he's
definitely hufflepuff and he was he was
addictive in every sense so he was like
you like the shirt there's like a blue
shirt i got i got 12 of them yesterday
and i was like okay man so we like we we
had eaten somewhere across the street
and we were like oh they had this really
good dessert there and then he was like
the next day he was like i tried it so
good i bought 16 for everybody here i
was like you are out of your [ __ ]
mind
so then when it comes time to settle
he's like uh he has a great week we'd
sold out the shows he's like
can you guess what you're uh getting and
i was like i don't i don't guess i know
exactly what i'm getting he was like how
do you know i was like well we have a
deal
so since all the shows were sold out i
know the amount of tickets and i know
the ticket price and then i know the
percentage
so then i know exactly what i'm getting
yeah he was like really i was like yeah
dude
like
that's how this works and he's like oh
yeah he goes we'll write down what you
think it is i go i don't think it's
anything i know exactly what it is
so
he's like well how much is it mark
summers who was the guy
what are you talking about so he gives
me a pen and paper i write down the
exact amount i go it is exactly this
amount and i show it to him he's like
that's not what i have i'm like then you
made a mistake you're wrong and so he's
like i have this and i'm like nope so
then he's like i gotta call like sandra
i'm like okay so then sandra comes up
and she just like works
she's all coked up probably big blonde
teased hair he's like tom said that he's
supposed to get this
and i have this and she was like hmm and
i'm like sandra listen there's nothing
to debate here
it is definitely this and then she looks
at me she's like
he's like i guess you're right
writes the chat i was like i'm never
coming back here again that's that's
like a venue where like i immediately
took that check i was like drive me to a
bank like right now because this is not
going to clear on monday the characters
on the wall are ari shafir eric griffin
duncan trussell dennis pappas chris
destefano andrew schultz jeremiah
watkins redband tony hinchcliffe sam
tripioli eddie bravo owen benjamin
christina p tom segura andrew santino
lisa ayat joey diaz crystalia theo van
of course the tiger belly squad bobby
lee kalila and gilbert joe rogan bill
burr and his wife brendan schaub brian
callan the fire and the kid crew so then
august 20th 2020 he goes to the red
studio which looks a lot like the chris
farley one except for it's the red
background in the wooden this past
weekend sign his first guest in there
was chelsea lynn episode 292. look i
think if you're getting congratulation
balloons you aren't doing enough with
your life i'm gonna go out on a damn
limb and say that
oh because anytime somebody needs to get
you damn balloons
to show that you have some kind of
damage
[ __ ] that's fine sometimes it's just
god i don't know you see some [ __ ]
walk over with a pack of balloons in a
damn you know and then my aunt one time
like they have a little thing that's
filled with a uh it has a balloon
another balloon that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's filled with something
confetti or
yeah yeah candy yeah yeah she would open
that and it's saying no but it was just
saying you know what i'm saying it was
just like saying and she if you're
buying a balloon in a balloon yeah you
got money
you got money that's not a regular
balloon you know
yeah you definitely got money there the
most viewed episode from the studio is
bobby lee's birthday episode 297. like
i've never
been over to like deleah's house
you know yeah yeah i love chris i think
that he's one of the best comedians i
think he's one of the funniest guys of
our time yeah yeah but i've never been
he's lived in three houses
physically funny i have been to been to
his latest house yeah i went to one of
his
houses and i had a pool he had a pool
party yeah and i waited in his pool
and then i didn't get invited to that so
that's kind of where he and i like yeah
you know yeah yeah yeah i was only
invited one time yeah and then i like
left and he goes why'd you leave i go i
don't like cheetos or whatever and he's
like that's all we have you know i mean
and then i like he never invited me
again yeah i went to dane cook's house
one time me too when he bought me a
sandwich
he did yeah he had some weird like party
where it was like me him marc maron by
swimming pool
just y'all three yeah yeah i was like i
don't like this
this is not fun at all imagine being in
a [ __ ] pool party with mark maron and
dan cook then on november 26 2020 he
moves to nashville opens up a new studio
there and has morgan wallen as his first
guest on episode 309 because i had a
band you know
and he was like well i wanna we're gonna
i'm gonna send you out on the road and
play some cover band shows and just make
sure just get you guys in your band just
a little tighter and you know make sure
you guys are good right excuse me
all right cool whatever what was the
band's name oh it was just me oh it's
still yeah you and your baby okay got it
go sorry but we were singing like like
we were playing like a long long sets
you know like
a couple three hours like a long time
right yeah you're doing weddings yeah
basically yeah yeah yeah
except i think weddings paid a lot
better
um
and you know there would have probably
been some hot girls
this was not that a lot of stuff that
this deal
oh
yeah just just got off the public golf
course
a lot of rosy cheeked old men huh yeah
santa's little helper
and uh probably this one man it was in
greenville north carolina
it was the first one we had done man
and
i
so the what they told us was we're going
to go to greenwood north carolina that's
where east east carolina university is
at okay cool you know it's like a it's
like a friday or something yeah yeah
there's sure there'll be a lot of let's
be some yeah the pirates yeah there'll
be some there'll be a lot of college
kids out here you know hell yeah we'll
be great then we get there and like the
first thing that dude says to us he's
like yeah by the way guys it's rush week
or something none of the fractures rory
is allowed to go out
that's bad
okay
great i'm not idiot you know maybe
there's some people that stuck around
this town that are a little a little
younger there's some people that dropped
out of school
they didn't make to the front you know
yeah
we'd go up there and i saw him as soon
as he starts saying that i start
pounding pbrs
in the middle of the day i'm like oh
this is going to be oh yeah this is
going to be bad that's the north
carolina state bird the pbr dog amen
[Laughter]
but uh
man
we get out there and i'm i'm pretty lit
dude and like honestly
we have not had a chance to practice
that much and there's a bunch there's a
bunch of songs on this list you know
so i'm down there making up words with
these songs
lit
singing there's like four people you
know one person kind of dancing a little
bit by himself yeah
yeah i couldn't tell you who was
actually there
but uh
i start
midway like do it i'm like halfway
talking [ __ ] to the to the crowd i'm
like god you gotta suck
so far his most viewed episode in
nashville is with andrew schultz but
we've played those clips so many times
so we're gonna do a shane gilles clip
his second most viewed episode in
nashville so far episode 353 we had a
professor i guess
i think then it was just a teacher you
know yeah and he would i remember he
drew a picture
of a wiener
ejaculating
chalkboard and it was he like kind of
described like he told us what the
feelings would be like we wouldn't be
able to handle it and stuff and then he
drew it like um
he drew the
ropes yeah the
coming out it was really insane was he
like
was he like making the noise with it
i remember he i do remember it was one
of those double chalkboards here comes a
big one
i remember he would put the marker on
the board and then walk
that's crazy it was pretty crazy man and
he wore the shortest shorts too he died
man willie i think
derek osner was his name or something
and i think his son might have died but
he died but his son died too i'm pretty
sure uh i don't want to say that but i'm
pretty sure
and he had the biggest mustache like i
don't know his words like i felt like
his words big mustache and he was
talking bro his mustache came over both
lips so it was like he's dead
the words couldn't even some of the
words you just had to guess what they
were people thought he was
some people thought he was black people
know what was going on
we just couldn't understand what he was
talking about it was crazy you know it
was just different times back then
it was different times so that takes us
now where he's in between the national
studio and the red studio kind of
switching it up traveling back and forth
thanks for watching this video make sure
you subscribe to joke world and shout
out to everyone who's followed us on
instagram and gotten these free stickers
we'll send them out to everyone let us
know where you post them send us some
pictures tag us and we'll repost that as
well
[Music]
[Music]
you